Senator Lindsey Graham with me now
Senate Judiciary Committee ranking
member sir good morning thank you for
your time your hearing starts in about
30 minutes my orcas will be there
what's your first question
well I'm going to paint a picture before
we ask questions I'm going to make the
case that America is really in an
undeclared war with the Mexican drug
cartels our nation is literally under
under attack by drug cartels and
president Mexico denies that they
operate in Mexico freely in certain
areas some will make the case we're
under attack and what are we going to do
about it I'm going to make the case
we've lost operational control of the
Border we went from the lowest illegal
Crossings in December 2020 to the
highest on record five thousand a day
I'm also going to point out to the
secretary that the number of people in
the terrorist watch list being
apprehended at the border is going up
like a rocket ship so my first question
is do you agree you're failing miserably
and what are you going to do to change
well
um I think we already know how he's
going to answer that and we know how
Republicans want him out of his job but
uh that that comes at a higher level
frankly but just two days ago we got
this tweet and the this on Instagram
from the president His official account
said Maga house Republican proposals
would slash funding for border security
A Move That Could allow nearly 900
pounds of fentanyl into our country we
need more resources to secure the Border
not less
your reaction on that here's my reaction
if you believe whatever problems the
House Republicans may have being solved
on immigration is not one of them this
is offensive to me that the president
would suggest that the Republican party
is weak On the Border Mr President since
you've been in charge everything has
gone to Hell in a hand basket you've had
the life of largest number of illegal
immigrant Crossings on your watch in the
history of the country the drug cartels
are poisoning more Americans every year
than are killed by car wrecks and gun
violence combined you have no solution
to these problems you withdrew from
Afghanistan and general Corelli the
centcom commander said within six months
Isis K Isis members in Afghanistan can
attack America without warning and one
of the easiest ways to do that is come
through a broken border so this is an
effort to deflect that will fall flat
fentanyl is now the leading cause of
teenage overdose deaths look at this
number here between 2010 and 2021 the
number of adolescent deaths from Black
Market Fentanyl
grew by 20-fold
the 884 in 2021. now amlo the president
of Mexico was just quoted the other day
as saying the U.S and Canada have more
fent on our country than Mexico
that's what he said listen he he also
urged people to vote Republican in the
United States He said hugs are better
than law enforcement what I would say to
the president of Mexico you're in denial
you denied uh a statement by secretary
blanken where he acknowledges that parts
of Mexico under drug car drug cartel
control not yours Mr President of Mexico
he's not a reliable partner so what's
going to change I've got legislation
I'll introduced soon to make drug
cartels foreign terrorist organizations
we need to put our military into the
game to stop this we need to destroy
these Labs on the ground in Mexico try
to work with Mexico to come up with a
different solution the law enforcement
model is not working we're literally
under attack there are more Americans
being killed by Mexican drug cartels and
Isis Al Qaeda the the Germans and
Japanese combined on the Homeland the
biggest loss of death in the history of
America by foreign powers is occurring
on President Biden's watch at the hands
of Mexican drug cartels and we're doing
nothing about it well political
campaigns might be able to change that
we'll see what happens with your hearing
first of all though at 10 A.M Eastern
Time Center thank you thank you thanks
thanks I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis